c'est pas d'hommes forts depuis le
premier ministre ontarien qui va décider
combien on gagne les médecins au québec
les médecins en ontario et mme erickson
ces gars de l'ontario 5000 $ plus fort
qu'en ontario monde beaucoup plus
d'aucun autre arrive c'est très à la
mode comparer que les salaires l'ontario
en effet
on a rarement entendu aussi souvent le
mot en ontario dans un débat des chefs
au québec
mais la comparaison entre les deux
provinces est elle toujours adéquate
on peut par exemple affirmé que le
revenu moyen au québec est inférieur à
celui de l'ontario c'est un fait mais
peut-on en conclure que les québécois
sont nécessairement plus pauvres que les
ontariens impôts vraiment l' indice des
prix de statistique canada démontrent
que montréal est nettement plus
abordable de parentaux ou à ottawa
prenons seulement le logement savez vous
que le coût pour se loger à montréal se
compare beaucoup plus à celui de saint
jean au nouveau brunswick qu'à celui
toronto où le prix du loyer est
nettement plus élevé autre exemple la
chaire de recherche en fiscalité de
l'université de sherbrooke démontre qu
encore aujourd'hui une famille avec un
ou deux enfants à plus davantage à vivre
au québec
en contrepartie un couple sans enfant
est moins taxé en ontario tous opposés
qu'au delà du salaire des profs ou des
médecins pour que la comparaison avec
l'ontario tienne la route
il faut tenir compte d'une foule des
scapin
[Musique]